bon joueur roberto giovannini merci de
répondre à nos questions comment est ce
que vous étiez la vaccination
obligatoire pour les plus de 50 ans
bonjour mais bon quel délit puni en 30
aujourd'hui qualité jours fériés et que
les jours de la bécane et on peut dire
dès mon point de vue c'est une bonne
décision politique parce qu'il ya enfin
les hommes politiques prend la
responsabilité
dans la vaccination obligatoire avec
tous les avantages et les avantages
avantages et les inconvénients des fêtes
décisions qui jusqu'à maintenant pour
les inconvénients
alors les avantages ses quais à partir
moins que vaccination obligatoire vous
êtes couverts dans tous les problèmes
aussi et des complications liées à la
vaccination c'est l'effet qui a étendu à
toute la population sam cloud et la base
volontaire et aussi c'est le coût de la
vaccination parce que pour le 28 mai
d'un futur ses saveurs douleur
renouveler la vaccination à partie - qui
la vaccination n'est pas obligatoire sa
ligne a forcément gratuite ni combien
c'est sûr qu'il faut décider quelle
catégorie est rentrée mais aussi il faut
on
prévoyait d une sorte d résistance qui
va peut-être aller jusqu'à des appels à
la cour constitutionnelle
du point de vue légal beau ça c'est pas
trop mon domaine mais je sais qu'il y en
a marre outil d'aidé à court d'un sais
pas mais moi je trouve les messages qui
est très fort et très intéressant
c'était aujourd'hui on considère dans la
balance bénéfices risques est vaccinée
c'est une solution meilleure plutôt que
de laisser le bio secourir et l'état
prend en charge le fait que les gens ne
doit très vacciner à partir de cet
instant soulage il a une grosse
polémique au niveau des différents
partis qui support la majorité des drags
parce qu'il y avait les parties les plus
hauts
et un comédien mais plus vers sinologue
qui proposait à partir de 40 ans les
moines qui peut reposer sur cinq ans et
donc on a fixé cinquante ans après je
pense qu'on aura lieu aussi l'éteindre
aperçu une personne qui avait des
pathologies à risque comme l'obésité
comme le diabète concède alain
aujourd'hui aussi qu'ils vont faire des
copies de grave ça je suis plutôt du
domaine médical
mais dis donc et voilà au moins
aujourd'hui l'état envers la société qui
montre une loi et surtout une bonne part
que choix hybride disant que c'est votre
choix mais si vous faites hors limites
mot liberté finalement juste comment la
population réagit par rapport à ça
plutôt que le choix hybrides dont vous
parlez comment est ce que les italiens
accueil accueil 7 cette obligation
alors pour moi malheureusement c'est
arrivé un peu tardivement dans le fond
ce qui aujourd'hui on a quand même deux
clans les vacciner les nomades signer et
city sort du pass a exacerbé les
différents je pense que de mon point de
vue on aurait dû l'appliquer du départ à
l'arrivée de la vaccination et empoté la
vaccination obligatoire peut-être pour
les plus de 75 ans sont cinq ans et tous
les pathologies à risque et après
affaires mesures voire l'éteindre
d'autres populations et j'ai dit je dois
dire que c'est donc moi ça va quand même
obligé partie personnes qui étaient
résistantes à la vaccination se faire
vacciner et et après aujourd'hui on a un
peu perdu la partie didactique on
n'arrive plus à
avoir cette solidarité qu'on avait vu la
première vague du coup forcément les
gens il faut leur donner des messages
est simple et fort et ça il faut rope
ladhuie relais gouvernement pour avoir
caché vous avez dit que selon vous il
aurait fallu appliquer cette obligation
plutôt à partir de 60 65 ans est ce
qu'on a perdu du temps selon vous est ce
que d'autres pays auraient dû agir comme
cela
alors qu'on m'a surtout la politique a
perdu beaucoup d occasions parce qu'il y
avait le moment sorti du colis dès
l'arrivée des premiers vaccins pour les
gens étaient très partante pour faire
vacciner forcément il y avait quelques
doutes quand ce qui est une banque saine
qui était préparé si rapidement et qu'il
y avait 1 où il à laval une recherche
donc la pub on laisse certaines étapes
dans les études ce qu'on pouvait faire
les études des faces des trois et quatre
responsables
forcément ça vous pouvez créer des
certaine suspicion et je trouve qu'elle
dira voilà c'est obligatoire sera permis
à jean des ratios ni l'art ni moi et a
fumé rendent compte qu'ils on a fait de
thérapie qui est utile pour contrer
c'est un pandémie mais d'autres côté
appartements qu'ils relèvent vaccins
obligatoires quoi qu'il arrive après la
victimisation moi je les porterai garant
je trouve si vous sur ça on a manqué une
cloche aujourd'hui je pense peut-être
bon après c'est facile de parler de
parler pour série messieurs message si
fort les gens ne sera fait vacciner avec
moins de soucis et aujourd'hui peut-être
qu'on aura un peu moins d'écart et à des
passions pas vacciner
l'autriche va rendre début février la
vaccination aux médias thouars mais pour
tout cela est ce que c'est la prochaine
étape selon vous en italie voir ailleurs
et pour moi ça je suis pas pressé les
problèmes politiques il faut pas oublier
qu'il est l'italie comme un pensionnat
une échelle présidentielle pour l'italie
c'est la fin du mois pour le prince un
peu plus tardive en bon les présidents
mon impact il ya qu un seul suffit voyez
la politique il ya des cas l'intérêt
politique qui rentrait dans le site je
pense pas pour le manque en aveyron
vaccination pour la population complète
est bon c'est fini il faut savoir aussi
comme le halal les nombre des cas vont
augmenter et cette nouvelle par un ami
troncy vraiment bas aussi remplir les
avocats des barreaux précédente donc
disons là je sais dire d'un côté dépôt
niveau médical escaut micron qui on sait
aujourd'hui être plus contagieux et être
plus létale et surtout est-ce qu'il va
saturer plus rapidement les rêves et ça
tout le monde perd son plus grand savoir
et notre question c'est savoir où à quel
moment la courbe et 20 des cendre et on
a déjà vu avec les autres variantes et
sur qui on va voir encore à monter
l'italie durant la période janvier
février et après la descente va être en
partie redémarre sa vie donc peut-être
que déjà avec la vaccination obligatoire
pour l'instant on arrivera un peu à
cloisonner virus et mons a pas obligé de
la allergie à tout le monde
merci umberto giovannini d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes médecin chirurgien et vous étiez en
direct de milan en italie